Bỏa.
Thì sống của bỏa nè.
Bỏa nè.
Bất mánh rào củaちゃん.
Nhà gặp.
Mánh cải của nhang soỳ bán của mây xác,
quần thảo, vừa giờ.
Ch hit rất liền, voy sực gió, các bạn chính,
đefa, mây một.
Khi sang đủ, tránh ăng đường,
mại tôi bị gún bay,
một số cu vực bỏng mất diện vàng gặp cục bộ.
Ngoài gặp tạng, là đặc đồng gió.
Chít ý khủ.
Đó cũng đúng, cái chuyện gì nhiều cơn gaw nhất,
gời tý lòng ngomo lòng khoảng,
lực lượng trưng năng cùng người dân dọn zap kê đồ, máy tôn và khách phục hậu quả sau báo.
Theo cơ quan khí tưởng, báo đã suy yếu và zi chuyển lên phía năng quảng tay Trung Quốc,
tuy nhiên hoàn lưu báo vẫn tức tục rei mời lưỡng và gió mạnh,
tại khu vực đông bắt quảng ninh.
Quý cơ ngập cũng lúc quát và sạch lợn đất tại khu vực biến đối vẫn ở bất cao.